(Music)
OK, so I'm going to give you a tour of the setup here:
So, we've got a thirty round magazine of .22 bullets
and we've got my Ruger 10/22 rifle--that I always use--,
I've got a controller
for a camera that's sitting at the other end of the garage.
So that's how we're going to trigger the camera in the dark.
We control the dark, here, by a little remote control...
...that flips a relay.
So that's how we're doing this.
So I am controlling:
the weapon,
the light,
the camera,
the flash
-with this--,
and... the delay generator.
Let's check the aim...
... of the weapon.
Aim on the weapon is good.
...get the flash...
... centered.
Test flash:
*snap*
Alright.
I think everything is good!
Let's load!
*sounds of shutter snap and gunshot*